(static buzzing)
(guitar music)
- [Narrator] It was spring 1967.
LBJ was in the White House,
the Vietnam War was in full swing,
and the biggest musical act in America was
The Monkees.
♫ Hey hey, we're The Monkees
♫ And people say we monkey around
- [Narrator] And that same spring,
a chance encounter in New
York City's Greenwich Village
would kick-off one of the strangest
and most ill-fated intersections
of pop culture in history.
(rock guitar music)
Here's Monkees drummer Micky Dolenz.
- Somebody said, you gotta come down
and see this incredible guitar player
that plays guitar with his teeth.
There was no name attached, nothing.
- [Narrator] That no-name
guitar player was none other
than rock and roll legend
in the making Jimi Hendrix.
- Flash forward--
- to June of that year.
It's the Monterey Pop Festival.
- [Mickey] And I'm
sitting in the audience.
All of a sudden, out walks these three
incredibly decorated characters.
And I just remember going,
that's the guy that plays
guitar with his teeth!
And of course by then they were
the Jimi Hendrix Experience.
- [Narrator] Micky was impressed.
- Everybody was blown away.
And I told our producers,
you gotta check this guy out,
'cause we were looking for an opening act.
- [Narrator] And despite some
fairly obvious differences
in musical style, a deal was struck.
- [Micky] Sure enough, the
opening act for The Monkees
was the Jimi Hendrix Experience.
- [Newscaster] A new group,
Jimi Hendrix Experience,
traveling with The
Monkees and they've joined
The Monkees' concert tour.
- [Narrator] So the two acts hit the road.
But, as it turned out,
fans who had come to see The Monkees
weren't quite sure what
to make of Jimi Hendrix.
- So he would go on stage to open the act.
And he'd be goin'
♫ Foxy Lady (imitates guitar playing)
We want Davy!
We want The Monkees!
It was kind of embarrassing, frankly.
- [Narrator] And things
didn't get much better
as the tour continued.
And after only seven
shows, Jimi had had enough.
- I did hear the rumor
at one of the last shows
he'd finally flipped off the audience.
(chuckling) I don't blame him, frankly.
- [Narrator] And just like that,
the unlikely marriage of
Hendrix and The Monkees
had come to an end.
Jimi of course went on to
be, well, Jimi Hendrix.
- Possibly the greatest
rock and roll guitarist
ever, as far as I'm concerned.
I'd like to think that we might have had
something to do with it, but I think
he would have done okay
with or without opening for The Monkees.
(rock music)
(electronic music)